and another concept that i think is
important is to have what i call
ruthless self-love
and that's just not this coddling
self-love of a spoiling grandmother
oh yeah eat the candy love it's that
ruthless self-love like this is what's
best for you
i'm looking out for you long-term i want
you to thrive in your life
and i'm going to give you what you need
to thrive and nothing else you know my
self-love does not talk that nice
my self-love is the get-up [ __ ] let's
do this [ __ ]
it makes a lot of noises come on [ __ ]
yeah don't be a [ __ ]
that's why it's ruthless you know but
it's not cruel it's not going to be that
it's not cruel it's not going to punish
you unnecessarily
oh you [ __ ] fat slob you lazy piece
of [ __ ]
that can happen it can happen and that's
and that's what you gotta watch you
gotta
have that that's the self-love part of
it you know the ruthless is that
intense like come on do it you know get
up get yourself done
this is what's best for you and then the
self-love part is not to
unnecessarily antagonize yourself
because we can be brutal to ourselves
i mean who who would we allow talk as
much [ __ ] to ourselves
as as ourselves right you know nobody
yeah
i think this the um the the term self
love is a funny one because people do
you love yourself don't you you always
knew you loved yourself
you know people there's a weird thing
about well if you don't love yourself
why the [ __ ] would anybody else love you
you know you should be a a person worthy
of your own love
and if you're not you're doing it wrong
it's really that simple it doesn't mean
worship yourself doesn't mean uh
pretending you're something awesome if
you're not it means
let yourself know when you're not
awesome let yourself know everything
you're doing wrong be completely honest
with yourself
and until you do that you're doomed
you're doomed
you're doomed you're never gonna get it
right you're never gonna get it right
if you don't look at yourself the way
other people look at you or even more
harshly
you're [ __ ] and then and then the
other component is
forgive yourself for these past years
we'll rehash these old things that we've
done so
far yeah that becomes new resistance
yeah you know these old past deeds that
were constantly lashing ourselves
the way to look at it in my opinion it's
just let yourself know you are
not the past you are who you are right
now and you could have [ __ ] up your
entire life
but right now you wake up and the way i
always describe it to people
pretend that you are a hero in your own
movie
and the movie just started now your life
is in shambles what would the hero in
the movie do